Shawn in Pittsburgh yeah I want to say a
couple things obviously the show wasn't
working a couple things that I want to
say is Jimmy didn't you go on the stern
show now you may have had a haze
blessing or they may have said go but
did you go on the stern - right after
the show went off the air and knowing
that you know all Stern tried to do to
ruin you guys you just kind of ran over
there is that some kind of integrity
issue there um I'm sorry I've never been
on her lap sorry sir sorry sir I am left
here with you guys
sir I am left he's right he's right
gentlemen right after the show was off
the air so I've never been on Howard's
show so why'd you go then show I've
never uh been on Howard's show sir oh
okay then I'm mistaken and I apologize
I'm sorry
you are and I accept your apology sure
did
never officer I'm pretty sure you did
actually okay well you sure that that's
fun no I do know that you be you be sure
that is your little heart desires not
only did I never go on Stern and he
never asked you to come I was like he
asked me and I said no but I never even
tried when we were off the air okay what
what I want to say Jim please let me um
I understand I was wrong and I apologize
well and so that's still after her for
the jury to decide quite frankly okay
but no I don't you I sure you did how
they do a little research myself I
thought yeah please do what I thought
was um what I thought was why the show
didn't work with a couple things one for
some reason you guys wanted to take it
to an area now whose decisions is worth
Bibles everyone take it to an area of
always having comedians in always having
interviews always having guests and the
best part of when you're sure what used
to be was just you guys drifting and you
know we don't want it to be intellectual
knocked over the head all the time you
know I don't want UFC guys in all the
time I don't want you know to hear
point of time one point time one point
the time we are doing too much
intellectual stuff with UFC fighters
well do when it was too much so the UFC
fighters this week is because they're in
town it's it happens to be a giant press
conference but I understand some guys
don't like the fighters and I get that
as far as the guests are concerned I'm
sorry I'm answering a question sir I'm
answering your question sir I'm
answering your question Shawn suck I'm
Esther your question Shawn Jesus Christ
Howard never would have did this when I
was on a show no and as far as the
comedian's after a point dude I didn't
book like guys like Chris and Sharad and
Vicky and I'm only naming them today
with the regulars I would never know
when they were coming in or mark they
would just be in Opie had that with
Roland taken care of I was very rarely
consulted on that but I like the guests
that were coming in a lot of the guests
so that was both Opie and I but the
daily comedians that were in uh was him
and but I would just kind of come in and
see someone sitting here and oh that's
who's in for the day but that became
more because we weren't enjoying each
other and again it wasn't a visceral
hatred it was it was just it wasn't as
fun for us so that is that answer your
question a little bit Shawn yeah yeah I
think you two can work there together
but family got to tell you night shows
best show I've ever heard and I hate to
see that go away um it gives me
something to do at night and I'm going
to miss it but I think you two if you
can not have guests in everyday and you
two just go back and forth and Jim I
love you guys but another thing is I
feel like a lot of times maybe you have
too much coffee that you just dominate
the conversation and you'll just slow
this up in I mean your little play on
words gets old after a while your your
characters that are in your head it old
episode yeah I know you saying how it
told them the same thing [ __ ] yeah I'm
sure they're wrong Robin didn't like to
joke so there's a lot of people that
don't like a lot of things I do shows on
the radio right we know yes and you know
sure all you got to do Jim is just sit
back and maybe let somebody else talk
once in a while I'm not sure what you
mean about me dominating the comments
Sam is a pretty
young man and Opie was pretty
comfortable talking I'm not sure what
you mean
but I I can't change the fact I'm
talking on with Norton and friends with
my pal Sam Michael always gotta pee
you don't always Sean Sean I appreciate
my preference yeah I says we move
forward is Jim that you continue to talk
at the same amount thank you so you've
been talking all right show me if we
gave you as much time you've listed a
lot of things you didn't like I tried to
address them right you started off
really on the wrong foot I onward
downward whooping how about if I play on
a field of something oh you think that's
funny
walking I know I know it a funny piece
of garbage it's really really it's
really annoying yeah yeah yeah but you
want to see the happy doing it maybe a
couple times a day a couple can we can
we can make that a couple times no it
can't be a couple what are you trying to
suck my pecker he's trying to suck my
phone compact Sean do you understand
that I would pay good money to watch a
live road show just between Sean and
chimp-like Sean is the perfect audience
for chip yeah [ __ ] yeah he knows what
he's talking about that's not funny
yeah it is hey Jim where you won the
[ __ ] whatever the show is it a Bill
Stern Show
Howard is his name what else you got
researches research that there's a my
[ __ ] on [ __ ] level in this
[ __ ]
Shawn is there any other complaints to
while we have chip in here no just take
it take what I say took a lot of us fans
still display know I don't know and I
don't disagree no you're right it's too
much negativity
awesomesauce ha ha ha like that's
awesome oh I have a couple more things
if you wanna you gotta say one positive
first yes so said a positive there's Jim
is an amazing comedian but what I don't
like no no you can't let me thank you
you can't let you can't not let me thank
you before you go on to the night you
can't say I'm an amazing comedian you
have to let me breathe and enjoy that
and go Thank You Shawn now you can
continue today you're welcome break the
fanboy of you and is another annoying
thing more things like we have guests
and just that you can get a picture you
can get their autograph yeah there's
been times run cha cha fanboy here's the
get the good and bad is this
there are times I'm too much of a fanboy
uh the these people have always said to
me when they've met me that I am really
I'm nice to them when they meet me and
I'm always trying to be very very
respectful and courteous to fans when I
meet them part of that is because I know
what it's like to be a fan of someone
else and not be treated well so it kind
of works both ways but yeah and maybe
I've done that too much fair enough
all right let's just have a great uh
whatever it's gonna be delicious let's
just move on and you know sharni looking
for a gig I'll never stop this today we
may right we chopped living I got three
shows you in the start there's nothing
else make good on this whole whole
serious except for sport there's nothing
else everything else is stupid move on
and hopefully we can you know pick up
where we left off the good old days for
taking my call it's very brave Thank You
Sean I appreciate ya yeah super brave I
don't think it's really scary I kinda
want to hire Sean as the new executive
producer yeah Jim stop doing the thing
with the characters yeah Jim what is
this I hear right after the show on
Thursday you went and did Howard show no
Sean okay all right I might be able I
still think you're wrong